let's read this
the first story here from timcast.com
breaking two men accused of governor
whitmer kidnapping plot found not guilty
two others receive mistrial the jury
deliberated for five days following a
two-week trial they're going to mention
on april 8 the jury found daniel harris
not guilty of one charge of kidnapping
conspiracy one count of conspiracy to
use a weapon of mass destruction one
count of possession of an unregistered
destructive device one
counter-possession of an unregistered
short-barrelled rifle
harris was the only one of the four
defendants who testified in his own
defense brandon caserta who was charged
with one kind of kidnapping conspiracy
was also found not guilty the jury
declared a mistrial on the charges
brought against barry croft jr and adam
fox the charges include kidnapping
conspiracy conspiracy to use a weapon of
mass destruction and possession of an
unregistered destructive device the us
government claimed the men had been
planning to kidnap whitmer at her
vacation home prior to the 2020 election
and arrested them in october of 2020.
all four men have denied the
government's accusations didn't it turn
out that um like the majority of people
involved in this were feds or some kind
of informant yeah like it wasn't even
like an actual plot let me show you this
from the daily mail they say how the how
undercover fbi agents infiltrated
militia group wolverine watchmen to try
to take down gretchen whitman whitmer's
kidnappers
they say what do they call it stoned
talk they say they said it was nothing
but stoned talk that the government
turned into a real conspiracy wow
schweers and bates both testified at
trial so so look without getting into
you know
hashing out the entirety of the trial
the story's been
i think for most people fairly obvious
as soon as they said yeah it was a bunch
of fbi agents that seem to have been
orchestrating the whole thing and then
blaming these guys who are bumbling
along for the fbi's own plan
along with this story and the story
about january 6 where the third trial
this guy was like the cops opened the
door and let me in the judge went yeah
the video shows the cops opened the door
and let you in not guilty the media
narrative on what insurrection the rise
of the far right it's all uh uh i'll
just bunk bs
bunk bunk
panel would you agree yeah i mean i
would tend to agree the entire narrative
started falling apart a couple months
ago and honestly when it was first
reported as a story i remember watching
my television regrettably checking
twitter saying wow this is really
horrible and for the people who are
actually committing legitimate acts of
violence and breaking in yes that's bad
i think we all agree that's criminal but
i should have known that the media was
spinning this trying to make it out to
be something it wasn't they started to
refer to it as an insurrection which is
interesting because it's an insurrection
where basically no one who went the vast
majority of people didn't have weapons
on them to try to overthrow the
government just a very bizarre narrative
but i think people were too afraid to
question it because they didn't want to
see him in support of it because our
media spent so much time calling it a
terroristic act
i just tweeted out earlier that i don't
trust screenshots pictures or video
anymore i don't trust it man i don't
trust narrative i don't trust the media
it's going to be even hard for me to
trust people face to face which i really
don't anyway but
man i don't want to get tainted on
humanity here but i am not i'm not
buying any of this crap anymore i hear
you but you're not necessarily getting
tainted on humanity i think it's okay to
acknowledge that known liars are known
liars and you shouldn't listen to them
without having a pessimistic view of
humans in general i think i think you
shouldn't trust cartoonists no
especially no so here's the thing and
now i would disagree i i think well in
most instances that's probably correct
but there are a few good apples yeah i
think that's exactly what an animator
would say i know right
if you have a bowl of m m's and 10 of
them are poison take a handful
not all bad apples hold on a second tim
that's that's ridiculous first and
foremost
eminems are all bad they're sugary
they'll kill you
what do you think lauren you think that
there's some value to this uh the media
narrative at the moment well i think
you're in a situation where you
obviously
had had you had a situation where people
wanted to expand the power of the
government where people wanted to expand
the power of security state
you wanted to see you wanted these
people to be dangerous
we've seen the fallout from this they've
been purging the military of people who
have any kind of connection to trump any
kind of support any any you know if you
were an nra member you could be on a
watch list if you were in the military
because of this and possibly up for
being removed so i think there this is
part of a larger
interest by kind of those in power to
make sure that you have the apparatus
that is able to
crack down on people and we we hear this
all the time from the media right that
the biggest national security threat is
you know the the white supremacists what
you know the these radicals you know the
these crazy q and on people this is
constantly being pushed for a reason
because it allows you to kind of take
that
war on terror apparatus and shift it
domestically and i think that you know
this isn't
i don't think that that's this is the
only part of it but i think that that
leads into that narrative for a reason
but you know that the response from
many democrat activist types is just
they're flabbergasted how is it that
fascists are getting away with all of
this because even when it's proven in a
court of law to not be true they just
say it is
so i i feel like regardless of whether
or not the state is is empowered by this
they got what they wanted
hardcore hyper hyper polarization in
this country the democrat activists are
still going to continue to be
radicalized by these fake news stories
the the acquittals in the january 6 case
and here do nothing to change that well
when you control the you know consensus
making apparatus there's no reason to
back off the story right if you continue
to push it it doesn't matter what the
facts were at the end of the day you
control the flow of information and if
you can continue to blast that out then
you know someone who really wants to dig
into it can eventually find it but the
vast majority of people aren't going to
do that and so the the narrative that is
you know sitting in people's minds is
that this went down everything you know
went down the way it was originally
portrayed no one goes back and looks at
these things you know years after the
fact to figure out if that was actually
the case and they end up taking the win
i was just watching a bunch of uh
documentary on the rise of the nazi
party in 1933 hitler point appointing of
goebbels to be the propaganda and what
was he the enlightenment minister some
crazy title
and they just they seized the radio they
they took control of it they shut down
over slowly over time first the book
burning which is in the schools the the
professors were like hey kids
don't wait for the the government to to
make this policy just go out there and
destroy the knowledge now the non-german
stuff so the kids were all like yeah we
think we're doing something good and
then when they got hold of the radio man
talk about manipulation they shut down
the other channels uh you couldn't get
anything out in germany if it wasn't
state propaganda control of information
but but
the issue is even with
the internet grants you the ability to
manipulate but also for the opportunity
for truth like people watching this show
right now i think the difference between
the people who watch this show versus
the people who watch young turks is that
for team cast ira listeners new
information will change their mind for
the young turks viewers new information
must be fake news and they'll completely
ignore it
so
like this story like january 6 they just
act like the revelation didn't happen at
all and so it almost feels like
the media narrative is is irrelevant at
this point
you know they could say anything and
these people would just be like we don't
care we'll do whatever you say no matter
what the story is that's called mass
formation psychosis i think i guess i
guess yeah we call it mass form
cognitive dissonance there's different
ways to describe the mental cult
failure or yeah i love i love these
there's there's a comic someone posted
on facebook and it's a woman reading a
newspaper and it says you know russia
claims there's no invasion and she's
like how could people fall for this
russian propaganda and then there's a
guy in a maga hat with q on his shirt
watching tucker carlson screaming about
a bunch of straw man narratives from the
left and i just thought it was so funny
i'm like this comic is irony it said us
bio weapons labs was one of the things
and i was like that's not the argument
the argument is biological research labs
they the left made that up and then got
mad about it and so that comic to me was
particularly hilarious because they're
mocking the right
for being indoctrinated but the comic
itself was indoctrinating them
it's just it was just pure irony because
those arguments were all strong man
arguments they weren't real arguments
coming from the right so i love it when
they say you know it was um um
scarborough was
he was referring to i can't remember i
can't remember exactly what he was
talking about but he called the right
occult
and it's just like it's fascinating to
me as there's an argument over trump
versus desantis who would be the best
person to lead in 2024 but on the left
they're willing to vote for joe biden
and mass even though they know it's
going to destroy everything
and they're and they completely ignore
breaking news facts and they're wrong on
every story i mean just go down the list
i think donald uh who someone tweeted i
should pull up the instagram image
somebody was pointing out every major
story russia gate hoax covington jesse
smellette kyle rittenhouse um now the
add two more to the mix the january
sixth story we got an acquittal it's not
trespassing the cops let them in oh get
ready for this wave of of narrative
implosion now the whitmer story two
people not guilty and mistrials the
whole thing hunter biden laptop
i'm sorry man when they just believe
things that are repeatedly debunked
they're occult
i completely agree yeah i can tell and
this looks very much like a religion to
me i was raised in a religious
environment and while i don't think that
that was in any way a cult you can
definitely see some of the overtones you
have your priests you have your acolytes
you have unforgivable sins you have
original sin sorry which is obviously in
our instance would be like being white
being male all of this other stuff that
you can't change and i would say
definitely this extends to women as well
because if you are not fully feminist
you are a sinner you're cast out and if
you're like candace owens you're cast
out as well it doesn't matter what shade
you are the only thing that matters is
connection to this ideology and complete
unquestioning devotion i've got a
definition of cult uh this from
wikipedia it was a so or this is from
what is this from wikipedia i think
social group with
socially deviant or novel religious
philosophical or spiritual beliefs and
practices so deviant or novel meaning
new so the word cult can be doesn't have
to be negative it's a new idea it can be
a new philosophy that a bunch of people
are rallied around colloquially it
refers to a group of people who
will not have their minds changed by
facts and adhere to a group structure
regardless of reality well i don't think
this is a particularly weird thing i
think this is actually very normal right
like your vast majority of societies
throughout history have been mediated by
some kind of value structure right you
have to have a coherent cultural
understanding of like who you are as a
people and what your values are and so
you have to have something by which not
only people judge their lives and the
value of their lives but also the ways
in which they defeat their enemies and
climb in social standing so this stuff
your devotion to this stuff is yes it is
a a way to find meaning but it's also a
way to obtain social status which is why
it's so important to signal your
constant agreement with the current
thing right because if you're not that
person the person next to you is and
they're gonna climb above you so i think
it has a lot of different different
functions and i i don't think it's
anything particularly unique throughout
history we're just seeing it because it
because it doesn't have an explicitly
religious nature because it doesn't have
an explicit holy book or someone at the
top who's the pope we don't treat it the
same way but it has pretty much the same
function thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you